What resources can partners bring?
Well, obviously if they have something you need
that you normally would have to develop
and they would sell to you or license to you,
that allows for you to get to market faster.
Or, it might be a complementary product or service
that you just couldn't afford to build or can't get around to for a while,
and that allows you to offer a broader product offering.
Or, yes you could do it, and you could probably do it in the same time,
buy why do something that's their expertise with your money?
It might just be easy to buy their product, integrate it in yours,
and now all of a sudden you're no longer doing their invention
but focusing on your core business.
For start-ups, trying to understand what it is you want to focus on
versus what is it you require in terms of activities and resources and suppliers
is a real strategy. Partnerships are not kind of an add-on.
They really allow you to capitalize on the unique customer knowledge
or expertise of others.
The final reason is, they might be channel partners
or they might be partners overseas to new markets
that you weren't planning to get to this year or even this decade
and allows you to generate a source of income
that would be unavailable to you for years.